bonjour à vous merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur rt france le président
azéri ilham aliev qui annoncent avoir
pris la ville de choucha une cité
stratégique pour quelles raisons
d'ailleurs cette cité est considérée
comme stratégique
déjà la ville de chouchi est le berceau
traditionnel centre historique très
important des arméniens de la soeur de
la république autoproclamée de l'artsakh
que les azéri dispute c'est une hauteur
stratégique réputée imprenable qui peut
dont la conquête peu à mon sens a décidé
du sort de la guerre en cours
alors les azéri nous ont habitués déjà
depuis trois ou quatre jours à plusieurs
annonces à plusieurs intox hier nous
avons eu droit à une mise en scène
cinématographique digne d'un film de
borat ou le président aliev en uniforme
militaire a proclamé la prise de cette
ville je pense qu'il faut être très
prudent à l'heure où je vous parle car
les combats sont excessivement dur on
est vraiment dans une logique de guerre
d'anéantissement de la part de
l'état-major turco azéri puisqu'il faut
prendre en considération que l'armée
turque est à la manoeuvre et que l'armée
azerbaïdjanaise qui a subi pas mal de
pertes plutôt dans un rôle de supplétif
mais aussi il faut comprendre
qu'aujourd'hui nous sommes le 9 novembre
le 9 novembre c'est une fête très
importante en azerbaïdjan c'est la fête
du drapeau et donc il est impératif pour
l'état major turc waziri que chouchi
puisse tomber afin de redorer son blason
et effectivement de déclarer la guerre
gagnée
l'arménie justement dément avoir perdu
la bataille
que faut-il en penser je pense qu'il
faut très prudent à l'heure où je vous
parle puisque nous avons beaucoup
d'informations contradictoires
beaucoup j'ai eu connaissance de
plusieurs tweets hacker de la part des
responsables arméniens du karabagh de
responsables astrium qui aurait parlé
d'une d'une défaite mais encore une fois
rien encore n'a été confirmée donc il
faut être très prudent
cela étant ça n'empêche pas de
d'affirmer que effectivement les
les armées l'armée turco azéri épaulé
par les mercenaires jihadistes sont aux
portes de la ville se battent dans leur
faubourg est effectivement chouchi tout
comme la capitale de la république du
karabagh stepanakert subit depuis trois
jours d'intenses bombardements par des
armements interdit prohibée par le droit
international humanitaire je vous
parlais de bombes à sous-munitions voire
de bombes au phosphore dans ce conflit
quelle est la clé finalement pour voir
un potentiel vainqueur si l'on peut
parler ainsi
je pense que si les arméniens
parviennent à défendre sushis et la
capitale stepanakert ils auront une
carte à jouer
pour l'instant les forces arméniennes se
bat seul les arméniens ont pour ainsi
dire de vrais ennemis mortels et de
vrais faux amis entre guillemets puisque
la russie ne considère pas le karabagh
comme une ligne rouge ni la présence de
militaires da2 d'officiers de l'armée
turque eux comme une grosse tout au plus
elle considère la présence de
mercenaires comme quelque chose de
difficilement concevable ce qui explique
les bombardements de l'armée russe dans
des camps de mercenaires en syrie une
des solution politique à ce conflit
serait de mobiliser la communauté
internationale ce qui est excessivement
difficile dans un contexte de pandémie
mondiale et d'élections américaines de
sensibiliser sur la nécessité de
reconnaître la république de l'artsakh
au titre de la responsabilité de
protéger
c'est un mécanisme qui a fait ses
preuves par exemple au timor oriental en
1999 qu'on appelle aussi la sécession
romaine
ce sera un moyen de protéger les civils
de cette république autoproclamée
tenant compte que la plupart des civils
ont quitté le karabagh pour éviter une
mort certaine compte tenu de l'intensité
des bombardements et donc des attaques
turco azéri alors vous parler d'eux
de médiation call médiation
particulièrement puisqu'il ya les
européennes vous avez évoqué aussi la
russie et comment parvenir à faire
stopper les affrontements qui perdure
depuis le 27 septembre dernier entre les
deux partis
pour l'instant les occidentaux sont aux
abonnés absents
la france malgré tous ses efforts en
tant que coprésidente du groupe de minsk
essaie de faire passer des résolutions
conseil de sécurité et c'est de proposer
ses bons son fils mais ne peut pas faire
davantage compte tenu du blocage de
l'allemagne qui soutient la turquie la
turquie qui soit dit au passage mène une
politique de terrorisme d'état tout en
étant quand même approuvé du moins par
l'otan puisque l'otan n'a pas désavoué
son allié turc
je pense que si solution il y aura et ça
ça dépendra de la poursuite des combats
et si encore une fois on parle au
conditionnel
si chaouchi et stepanakert sont défendus
on va on va s'orienter vers un sorte de
10 une sorte de médiation en tout cas
turcot russe puisque la turquie
manifeste son intention de rester dans
le caucase de déployer des forces de
maintien de la paix avec la russie est
pas six mois ce mauvais néologisme on
pourrait s'orienter vers une sorte
d'astre anisation du conflit du karabagh
c'est à dire une répétition du scénario
qui déjà en cours en syrie
vous avez une sorte de condominiums syro
turque qui pourrait être éventuellement
encore une fois déployés mais cela c'est
là encore une fois il faut parler au
conditionnel puisque on ne sait pas
encore de quel est le sort de shoushi et
pour terminer l'hypothèse d'une
intervention militaire étrangère dans ce
conflit rapidement c'est possible c'est
déjà le cas puisque la turquie et est
sur le terrain les russes ont bien
précisé que si il considère que le
territoire de la république d'arménie et
sanctuariser est sous la protection d'un
système russe anti missile ils ne
tiennent pas à se déployer au karabagh
pour la simple et bonne raison qu'ils ne
tiennent pas non plus a coupé tous les
ponts qui les lie à l'azerbaïdjan la
russie a des relations d'amitié et un
partenariat avec l'azerbaïdjan
or ce qu'on voit c'est que leurs badges
en déplacer son curseur à 180 degrés
vers la turquie et il sera important
pour la russie de garder un levier de
pression
d'où sa non intervention entre
guillemets sur le terrain des eaux
gracias merci beaucoup à vous à thégra
nay et garhyane je rappelle que vous
êtes membre de la rédaction de la revue
géopolitique conflit et spécialiste du
caucase